at leighton sixth form college students
know their school's
past performance is a factor in their
results the school of course is impacted
by its social
and economic surrounding so then is the
modeling of the students grades
and at this east london school of qual
has downgraded 47
of their teachers predicted grades as
the students are about to discover
i got bbc but i was expecting aaa so
they ruined my results
are you going to challenge that yes
definitely because this is not what i
deserve
i don't have the grade to go to
university i don't feel like i've been
fairly marred because
i thought my predictors are way higher
than this i feel like it's really just
put the last two years to waste because
they didn't really validate what
the teachers were saying about students
because at the end of the day if you
have a teacher for one or two years
that's better than a computer system the
teachers here are angry that the hard
work they put into their assessments
have been
ignored and the students have been
marked down
feel that their individual achievements
at this school recognized by their
teachers
have been stolen from them by an
algorithm
here's how it works first the students
are given grades but are also
ranked by their teachers the program
then applies
other factors if the student cohort
performed less well in previous years
for example in their gcses
an adjustment is made the predicted
grades are also
set against the schools past performance
matching with previous years
can jostle students further downwards
half of your students
have not got the results that you think
they should get
yeah and that's a really hard message to
communicate to them because what they're
doing is they're showing me a piece of
paper
and i'm having to say to them that's not
what we think
you would have got or deserve to have
got across the uk
overall grades have risen on last year
but grades at a and above rose nearly
five percent
in private schools compared to two
percent in state comprehensive
perhaps because the algorithm gives more
weight to teacher assessments if they
have smaller class sizes
and at this top performing state school
in surrey they also
question the methodology of will tell
you that everything's been done really
reasonably and that the
model is the you know the best it could
be but it clearly hasn't worked here
and there seems to be growing evidence
that it's not working or hasn't worked
well
in a number of high-performing state
schools
the alternative would have been to
accept more generous teacher marking and
grade inflation
either way the class of 2020 was
destined to become
an educational anomaly jason farrell sky
news